on tuesday california voters
overwhelmingly pass
proposition 22 allowing app-based gig
companies like uber and doordash to
circumvent state law
and keep their drivers independent
contractors a
major win for gig companies the victory
means app-based drivers are exempt from
ab5
a california law requiring most
independent contractors to be
reclassified as employees with workplace
benefits
uber ceo dara koshoshahi has called prop
22 the third way to
classify drivers while retaining
independent contractor status
drivers would get some benefits of
employment such as 120 percent the
minimum wage
health care stipends and vehicle
insurance
gig companies poured a historic 204
million dollars into the campaign
supporting prop 22
making it the most expensive initiative
in california history
labor groups and democratic lawmakers
fought hard against prop 22.
they argued independent contractor
status deprives drivers of basic
workplace benefits and that companies
are getting away with not paying local
and state taxes on employees
two recent analyses found that the
measure wouldn't deliver the minimum
wage promised by gig companies
as their estimates only factor in time
spent actively driving or making
deliveries
and doesn't count the time in between
riders or orders
you